that's not the right camera
just I'm just posting up that was
shelling yeah this is something you can
do this is something that you can do to
help right now there we go you know fire
blasts what's up hey what's up yo
welcome hi guys so what we're here to
show for today
it's called calm pencil there's been a
lot of people already hard at work so
you can go to our github URL right here
uh that's github calm / calming I slash
Tomic comic 10k and it's 10k images for
training cities yes it's comic colouring
2.0 it's comic larry 2.0 so tesla has
this thing called data engine car path
you loves to talk about it he talks
about it a lot of talks we of course are
too poor to afford a data engine so
we're relying on the kindness of
strangers and these strangers over here
this is our discord if you don't know
it's a discord comedy I have been
incredibly kind we're gonna go over to
comma pencil and they've already labeled
the first thousand images for us so we
can go through we can just take a look
at some of these here what's up Previn
they're really they're really beautiful
I think and it's easy because you don't
have to label things too many different
colors alright so um if I go here by the
way this is all open source so unlike
with comma pencil any work you do here
is available for anybody to use for any
purpose under the MIT license I can go
in and out here so one of the beautiful
things about comma segments is we don't
have many classes we don't have many
different kinds of stuff that you have
to label you don't need to know the
difference between someone who likes
watermelon and
who doesn't like watermelon I mean maybe
those are three different types of
categories or you know what's the
difference between a truck and a pickup
truck all right when is it a truck when
is it a car I don't know but what I do
know is that commas categories are very
simple five categories see this purple
here
this category is called my car anything
that is inside of your car and moves
with you some guy put a pizza box on the
windshield this is the my car category
this red here is a lane line we have
lane lines that dark brown is a road we
have everything else oh yes well the
green is movable so that's like cars and
pedestrians and horses anything else
that moves and then there's everything
else which is just that that grey there
right so yeah I mean you can see this is
just labeled from our users right here
on our github all this is open source so
we're going for ten thousand images
we're up to the number labeled so far
well no what happened don't modify the
images folder oh we got a we fix the
test cuz I modified the images folder
but
that is how many we've labeled so far
ten that 1049 images so you can like
look at them they're really beautiful
you guys can look at me for a minute
I'm George my name is George Wade you
are on the internet sometimes and you
can find me on how many I discord well
you can come help out right now with the
comma a eyepencil project while i come
fix this test we're going to fix this
test don't modify the image folder wait
what oh no
I need somebody else to fix this I don't
know how to fix that don't modify the
images below thank you thank you
Iowa's we're just going in here we're
gonna we're gonna you guys want to see
the keyboard and I love seeing the
qiblah oh just gonna go over that we
gotta fix this test because I don't want
people thinking that my test is broken
but that's just sad
oh this wasn't the right way to fix this
[Music]
just do it like that see if this one
works - all right guys we fixed the
tests now we can get back to comma
penciling with you guys check out how
beautiful this image looks look at that
every little lane line right where it
belongs
and you guys can contribute to this huge
corpus of work that's publicly up on
github and is about to now have tests
that pass let's save the test pass fix
tests did I fix the tests oh I don't
know we're gonna find out so you ask
yourself how do I contribute to this and
Eric B has written this tool that you
guys can use called Image labeler
um image labels like the comma pencil
tool but it's better uh
you can type in like say I want to go to
50 or show the existing mask this one's
already really well labeled but I can go
to one that like isn't labeled yet lets
go to 1600 let's show the existing mask
for that oh look at that
look at that bug it's really obvious you
know especially if I lower this down no
I don't you know it's not a bug no no
nevermind it's not obvious moths
oh yeah look okay you can see it you can
see it if the mass capacity is not that
high you see here this is actually not a
part of the truck it's a part of my car
so I can just go select my car here
go around this yeah beautiful I don't
know if I see any other bugs with this I
think there might be some stuff
unlabeled over here let's zoom in yeah I
think that's supposed to be a car
doesn't that look like a freight truck
to you I will just go to movable label
this guy movable
drag those out a little bit well I want
to do that yeah yeah drag that there all
right cool all right
oh my there's like little blotches over
there that aren't great but either way
this is a whole lot better than what we
had so when I'm ready I can just save
this mask it's downloaded here and then
you can commit that math on github I
like use the up and down arrows to
change opacity oh that's nice
awesome quality software oh yo Edwin
knows what's up um so yeah now I've made
this mask and now I you know if you're
gonna do it you should put a lot more
love and care and do it than I did we
really want these masks to be pixel
accurate and not have splotches like
that this is too low quality to commit
to our repo right over here in the comma
discord over in the comma pencil channel
and you guys can come help out so you
know Tesla has this they call it data
engine we don't have data engine because
we're poor guys we're poor comma doesn't
have a lot of money if you want to give
us money go to shop comment on the I and
by comma twos but got the tool we use
pin to all we should definitely do that
oh that's a good point yeah let me just
so I be wrote this on discord it's a
great tool if he's doing a great job PGA
Laos down tons to you know actually
labeling images himself getting all this
stuff emergent on github virtually Chris
has been helping out with that got we've
got a great crew shout out to John Smith
for buying a seat to did you buy a comma
to just buy right now able to advise one
right now on this livestream I will
shout you out I will shout you out John
Smith's just play Oh guys guess what we
sold today my love when we sell these
okay so I don't know if you guys have
been to come ai slash services but we
sell some ridiculously overpriced
services to people and we sold a meeting
today we sold a 30-minute phone call for
$1000 John Smith bought one for one I
don't know my Shopify doesn't scroll
back that far that was so
longer um now you know people aren't
people aren't driving as lunch with the
UH you bought one yesterday Michael home
no no I can I can I can see you if you
bought one yesterday you did buy one
yesterday Wow oh yeah no [ __ ] tomorrow
uh no I'm not gonna show ya 30 minutes
for a thousand dollar phone no we were
building something incredible right now
there's a quick picture of it up on the
discord but all the comma twos that ship
out from now on are gonna have stress
testing that's super important but
remember how can you contribute oh I
can't show your shopify um but I can
show you kama 10k how can you contribute
go to this github URL actually did I fix
the tests well I fixed that don't modify
the image just follow this that's good
the images are really honestly beautiful
so these are the ones that have already
been labeled now we can get to some of
them that haven't been labeled yet
yeah yeah so like these ones
well this one was automatically
generated so you can see that it's quite
good so this this is an automatically
generated mask which means we just ran
it through the the comma automatic stuff
you see that's quite good here it's
quite good here but it did miss this car
over here so you know we need somebody
to go in and just label that car maybe
that edge should be cleaned up a little
that's a little it's a little janky
looking yeah I don't know maybe that's
okay what do we have here again these
ones are all completely labeled by the
computer this one looks very good
already I don't know if there's any
problems with that one the only problem
I see is that if you zoom in here
there's a little bit of a little bit of
red there now remember that we don't
label crosswalks as Lane lines because
they're not lay mines they're crosswalks
now what do we got here oh this one's
pretty bad so you look at this unlabeled
Lane here remember every bug you see in
these images is a bug in open pilot so
every bug that you fix is a bug that
gets fixed and open pilot we're gonna
use this to regenerate all of our ground
truth once we have this segment um so if
you guys come to our github come to our
discord remember that the discord comedy
I come in this channel right now I'll
post want you chatted on screen right
here yeah but people will help you I
know that we're gonna get play of this
later people will help you get set up
what is a segment a segment it's just
something that automatically labels that
so it's the machine that I use to
automatically generate this mask so
remember this one again Emilie's
automatically generated by the machine
and that's why it's not perfect with the
human ones were much higher quality cuz
see it's not really a lame there it's
missing a little lane here that stuff
still Allroad this one looks pretty good
it was like blotchy stuff and it's a bug
down there you see that should be my car
I should be purple again we're missing a
center lane line you know have you ever
had
and pilot not detect your center lane
line well you can fix this right now by
contributing to common pencil we're
apparently missing an entire semi every
time you label a picture the AI gets
better exactly exactly
you guys can contribute guys can label
data help me out this is the thing that
I've been using to test them off you
guys heard about big model look at big
model this is what the model currently
sees this is big model you know it's
like an ad for a widescreen camera we're
missing an entire salmon you guys want
to see we're missing an entire semi what
do you do if someone missed labels we
don't merge your pull request so this is
on github we have a system we are a
complex system place of checks and
balances we have an executive branch
alleged No
so like here this one ah see and now we
have virtually Chris came in here on our
public github here and it was fine for
you and it tries to put you in another
Lane well you guys you know contribute
see look look look look at the detail
here look at the detail that's being
called out all this is incredible
see this is the kind of quality that's
gonna make open pilots so good I've been
super impressed with people's attention
to detail here uh yeah virtually chris
has really been the guardian of the
guardian of quality so if you submit
something that's bad
someone will call you out on it and
we'll get you to we'll get you to fix it
up but yeah
oh yes y'all wish you were missing up
those people should be green if they're
not green those Lane lines should be
colored an they're not colored an oh
this is pretty bad this one's pretty bad
we could do better here guys we can do
better you guys can do better we label
this one all this one's crispy
I just want to cite from like a few
mislabeled ley lines far off in the
distance that looks pretty perfect
this one's very good um big improvements
already one of the big improvements that
we didn't have before was all these
things used to not be labeled cars now
they're being labelled cars thanks to
thanks to people labeling them so that's
really nice so a few labels yeah we
don't need a lot of labels we're not
Tesla is there no way to use temporal
context to improve segmentation while
moving so we actually do that um we
actually do the only reason do we do
some tutorials come into common pencil
and people will help you get started um
so we use temporal context in the final
ground-truthing model like in the in the
Ottoman so these models are used as a
component of our automatic
ground-truthing system for the big
models and the fact that they've worked
at all even with the super low quality
of data we've had is testament to how
good that temporal smoothing works we
don't want to put that temporal
smoothing in here because then you're
gonna get to poor correlation the beauty
of this is its iid so we can you know
you can it's much easier to train models
when things are a deed you don't have to
deal with you know if you're gonna put
it into a filter later right like you if
you're gonna put some in a cow milk if
you don't want to be completely
correlated so that's why we do this like
this we don't try to exploit temporal
information here yeah let's look at a
few more let's call it a few more about
this one see this one is almost perfect
the only thing I would say here oh I
wouldn't label those things Road though
they kind of are Road driveways kind of
our roads sometimes I don't know I don't
know if I'd call that a driveway I don't
know what people have been doing coming
to come with pencil and ask about that
um any thoughts about the University of
Toronto self errand car Chris I don't
know anything about it oh there's a bug
there look that shouldn't be purple
that's not part of your car
it's just a splotch on the road leaned
that up
that's that image by the way if you want
to come off yet hub right now fix that
one that one can be yours to fix for the
low price of zero dollars and cleanup
that maybe maybe get a little more I
think that Lane goes out a little bit
more I think you can kind of see it if
we zoom in a little bit there oh yeah oh
wow I'm missing a vehicle off in the
distance oh that could be bad that could
be bad we want to definitely get that
vehicle labeled
yeah let's see that shouldn't be that
shouldn't be rode there
oh look at that one little lanes watch
David did a pretty good job with his
vehicles they remember these are the
ones they're being automatically
generated so if we look back at some of
the ones that were human labeled the
humans have really done a great job they
look at this I don't know I bet we can't
find any bugs they've done a great job
looking even got like a car over here
and stuff um so yeah big props the
humans because really like how good this
is saying in machine learning and it's
called garbage in garbage out but you
can take that saying and you can also
say quality in quality out maybe if your
machine learning is good you might get
garbage out but if you put quality and
that's where you got to start cars and
trucks green yeah the color standard so
the colors are all listed in the in the
readme here and we talk about what the
categories are here so oh yes you guys
are correcting the AI um the categories
are pretty simple so there is no more we
don't care about sky we don't care about
signs in traffic lights anymore we just
care about five categories road lane
markings undriveable movable and my car
so Road is all parts anyone nobody would
look at you funny for driving the
driveway looks real private no if a
parking lot yes don't include non lane
markings undriveable is anything you
can't drive on like the sky or like a
concrete barrier movable or like people
and vehicles and signs are also
undriveable right hand countries work
fine
yes absolutely even on my desk
we've yawns and common tools was that
this new hardware um I have a neon
because oh no I did make a change today
notice how it doesn't say panda anymore
it says vehicle no GPS I'm not sure you
guys can really see it but this is
actually yellow because you're gonna
need to cuz this is a white panda this
is the greatest project you've heard
about so far thank you thank you so my
white Panda and my comedy bug
no new harbour yeah so if you guys can
come onto our discord somebody will help
you out and yeah that's pretty much all
I have to say oh yeah if you want to
schedule a meeting
it's $1,000 we sold a meeting today I'm
so happy I love when we still meetings
great victories I've been meeting
tomorrow my $1,000 phone call
any idea why your Don your ego has your
default location wrong bro I don't know
how to write that code source check that
check source go check the check the
source all right cool
any other things for this dream we'll
just look at a bunch more pictures while
we answer any last questions beautiful
these are human label this is this is a
testament to what humans can do when
they're motivated look look at how far
those Lane goes yeah yeah beautiful is
there a channel yeah it's called kama
pencil in discord in the comment I
community discord yeah ah ah beautiful
beautiful look at that look at that blue
reflection no still a vehicle ten
thousand images to label yeah I mean so
the thing about ten thousand images it's
already getting a whole lot easier to
label the images I think by the time
we're at the last thousand we're gonna
have to change maybe a hundred of them
and I think nine hundred them are
already gonna be labeled completely
correctly so we're doing this
iteratively I'll show you yeah
find what I'm looking for this one so
you can see this is this is a segment
that I've been learning this isn't a
good example we've got a better example
up here I'm playing with dynamics models
here we got a second out with extra day
yeah yes you can see like we're just we
learned segments and then we use it to
predict and get these so as you guys
label images this thing let's get
smarter the segment's get smarter we
have to label less and less things yeah
we trained entirely with
right-hand-drive stuff it'll be fine we
gotta start paying you for column points
no um nobody has bought the data yet no
nobody has bought the data we won't pay
you for comma points when I read it pays
you for karma that's that's what I like
to say about paying for common points
nobody's bought the data yet
unfortunately unfortunately guys and I
wouldn't sell the data to people if they
suck if they want to do ads you know
[ __ ] you no way mo Senna sauce and a
Senna sighs shouldn't say that I
shouldn't say that but you know [ __ ]
Weibo I will say that well apparently
apparently this is podcast and the
podcast bleeped out Weibo and replaced
it with Taco Bell because but just wait
no socks no but um and only weird edge
cases oh yes
yes and actually we'll show them to you
so hey virtually Chris welcome welcome
to the channel we'll show you the hard
ones so we went out of our way to find a
hundred of the hardest images wow this
one's already been labeled by a human oh
this one's been labeled by a human as
well but wait'll we get to some of them
that haven't been labeled by human look
at this guy
these are the hard ones wait'll we get
to the ones that haven't been labeled oh
yeah look at that look it's total trash
so we did a search yesterday for where
the models are the most confused and
then we we put them we put them in oh
yeah look at this look at
trash it thinks that's part of your car
all that's junk okay that one's good
someone probably do that go oh look at
that aw it doesn't work at all those
police cars are clearly movable vehicles
can't even tell what they are
oh this is this is the worst one oh
what's the discord list discord kama die
wow yeah this one's really bad you guys
can fix that one it's called H zero zero
nine and it's called H cuz the H stands
for hard Oh terrible oh that's terrible
oh this one's someone dead like this
pretty beautiful oh oh look all that
vehicles is coming right for us bro is
coming right for us someone better label
it real fast like it thinks those lights
are lame lines that's how atrocious this
is Wow look at that mislabelling
terrible terrible
didn't do something at that one but yeah
we went through and I filtered out what
the hardest ones were yeah we got act
passed with the Karl had us come on
label label label alright so yeah if you
can come in and help out on how to
accept lane marking tab enter I don't
know what that means
but look oh look at this look at this
terrible image look look at how bad it
is at this pop car he has clearly a car
plans for zero eight white pandas no
longer supported look at that vehicle no
GPS no we're gonna we're doing lots of
stuff with the localizer to start to
actually drive using the localizer to
put information back into the vehicle
basically we're improving the vehicle
model so it won't like drift out on
turns anymore we're looking at the
hugging issues and we're looking into
big model if we ship big model if we
ever ship big model it'll ship in the
zero eight I think zero eight is a
beautiful time for big model look at how
much more model we can see there's the
outline for zero rates on I'm your
co-pilot uh github is ball GMC yukon XL
no no don't buy that no biome Impala
compatible car by him dice nada
look at that I've got to fix that move
over for Sammy yeah it's on cruises I
have one song on Spotify parking lines
or Lane lines no parking lines are not
line lines now only if they're used to
mark a lane I'll look at this also I
think someone labeled us why this one
was already just good you know I think
someone labeled us oh that's nice
us crispy crispy alright I'll leave you
guys with one of my favorite I think it
was 57 57 is one of my favorite yes
Ritchie's English enriches your English
Hyundai harness I don't know we'll have
to ask the gender harness team yeah that
was labeled you makes a huge difference
this one looks kind no as well wasn't
really labeled look cuz that stuff still
wrong but this one's already pretty good
Ritchie's English and riches are English
I'm gonna leave you guys with thank you
for watching make sure to check out
comma
pencil on this cord everywhere label
images help us out
don't make us you know like Tesla had to
like pay a lot of money for this and you
know like let me tell you something
who cares more you when it's your open
pilot that's gonna miss the tech delay
nor miss detector car or some random guy
in the Philippines who can never afford
a Tesla in his life that's right you
this is a community-supported project I
really value you all thank you so much
for coming in to help out if you have
and if you haven't come in and help out
if you have no intention to come and get
to help out you're just here to enjoy
the show that's all good to thank you
all for watching good night well a lot
of people want that Hyundai honest all
right all right all right I hear you I
hear you I hear you
yeah Ford stocks don't buy for